では よろしくお願いします
今日のお話はまあ役に立つかどうかちょっとわかりませんだけど
まあ皆様まあよくご存じテーマだとも思います
それで特に今日気をつけるポイントっていうのは
この習慣パターンというのは人間の幸福を左右するんだっていうことで
まあそれも説明しなくてもよくわかることだと思います
そういうわけで 皆様方
知ってるところを説明しないで
それ説明しちゃうと なんか私はあまり勉強していないっていうことバレますので
まあ知らないところ説明したいと思います
知らないところだからね
勉強しているかないかわかりませんしね
で  いつでもやっている定義なんですけど
で 癖というのは何なのかと
癖の定義 無意識的な行動ですね
意識的にやるんだったら癖とは言わないんです
わざとやってるんだったら癖じゃないんです
だから無意識的な行為なんですね
これがまたやめるのはね
簡単じゃないんです 癖っていうのは
大変です やめられないんですよ
一応 別に意識的にやってるわけでもないんだからね
それで自分に聞いても
なんで私にこんな癖がついたんでしょうかと
わからないでしょう 自分でもわからない
なんで自分に癖があるんでしょうかと
だから大体自分の癖っていうのは自分でわからないんだから他人が言うでしょうに
だから私にしたっても
私に何の癖があるのかと自分ではあまりわからないんです
それは他人が言ってくれないと
全然気づかないんです
それから次の 3 4番目からは
えーと ここからはちょっと皆様あまり気にしないことやと思いますけど
これから仏教的な定義なんですね
3番目 癖は行動パターンに限ったものではありません
私たちは思っている癖っていうのは
ちょっと鼻をかむとかね
目蓋を触るとか まあそんなもんなんですけどね
で そういう行動パターンに限ったものではありません
癖っていうのは心にも癖があるんですよ
今日勉強するのはそれなんです
注意するべきなのは心の癖です
体の癖っていうのはそんなにどうったことはないんですよ
時々人がいますね なんかやけに首を振ったりするとかね
いろんなことを体のことをいろいろやってますけどね
そんなのはそれほど問題ではありません
心の癖 世間では心の癖っていうところは勉強していないと思います
ですから 今日の勉強は心の癖なんです
で 誰にでもあります 癖は誰にでもあるものです
ですから この癖がない人っていうのはいない
それは日本でもなんとかことわざがありますから
ないと言ったっても 七癖があるんだとかね
だから体の癖でもない人はいませんし
心の癖でもない人はいませんね
それで誰にもあるんだから
別にそれを批判的に見る必要もないんです
仏教の立場から言えば
すべての生命にあるものです
それで仏教になってくると
人間の癖っていうわけじゃなくて
生命に癖があるんだと
だからすべての生命に癖があるんですよ
皆様はすべての生命を知らないんだけど
まあ動物ぐらいは知ってると思います
だから動物なんか調べてみてください
一人一人自分の癖っていうのは持ってるんですね
同じじゃないんです まあ動物の場合は習性というかね
動物ならではの行動もありますからね
猫科の動物だったら必ずスネを研ぐし
で ネズミの系のね アリスとかね
そういう動物は必ず 何かを噛むんですよ
噛んで噛んで自分の歯が伸びるんだからね
前にあるあの 4本の歯がありまして
犬歯でしたっけ あれがずっと伸びるんですよ
だからまあ 何かを噛んで何かを噛んで
それを短くする でないと口が閉めませんだからね
で それは習性です どんなネズミもやってる
どんなネズミもやってるかもしれませんだけど
それ中でもやっぱり癖があるんですよ
猫の爪の研ぎ方にもやっぱり癖があるんです
そういうふうに習性の中でも癖がある
だから全ての生命だから神々にも癖があるんですよ
神様になったんだから
もう大丈夫やってことじゃないんですよ
いろいろ癖がついているんです
生命に共通な性格の一部として考えた方がいい
だから生命たるものには
まあ誰にでもある一つの性格の一部
どうにもならない性格の一部だと思った方がいいんです
だから この癖の勉強っていうのは
あんまりこの嫌なものやとか感じでも見てはいけないし
いいものという感じでも見てはいけないんですね
する ただ 誰にでもついているものであると
で 次の問題 これからもう内容に入ります
定義のところは終わりました
癖っていうのは善玉ですか
悪玉ですかと これが複雑ですね
日常の我々の癖を見ても
これいいか悪いか ちょっと言いにくいんですよ
で 例えばよくものすごいでっかい声で喋る癖の人がいる
喋り出したら止まらない癖の人もいるし
私も一人なんですけど
で なかなか止まらないんですね
で 聞いてる人は一人なのに
80人が来たっていても聞こえるような
すごいもう 大きい声で喋る人もいるしね
あるいはもうもう人に聞こえない
喋っても明確に そういう人もいるしね
だからそんなのは悪いかいいかどうかね
まあそうか 簡単に判断はできない
まあそれも聞く人の態度ですね
まあ大きい声が好きな人だったら
あの人はすごく まあ来たらもう何て言いますか
まあ結構活気的でいいんじゃないかという人もいるし
あの人ならもううるさくてうるさくて
あんなでっかい声で喋っちゃうとも
他の人には喋らなくなっちゃいますよというふうにまあ悪く見る人もいるし
だから癖が善か悪かっていうこともなかなか決まりにくくて
もう相手が判断することになっているようなもんなんですね
でも他人様が判断したってもね
それは他人様の主観で勝手で癖であって
人がこれ悪いと言ったっても
悪いかないか分かりませんでしょうね
それがその人の癖ならどうしますかね
例えば何だかんだ悪い悪いという癖があるんだったら
いいものに悪いと言っちゃうでしょうに
だからわからない 複雑ですよ
癖が善玉か悪玉かということは
善でも悪でも 生命には付いてるもので
止めるにも止め止められないのは事実です
もし善の癖もある 悪玉の癖もあるとしたっても
これはもうやめるにやめられませんよ
ついてるんだから 自分でも知らないんだから
なんでそんなことをやっているのかと
だからそれが癖という特色の癖というものの特色なんですね
しかし だったらしょうがないでしょうと
例えば ものすごいでっかい声で喋る癖の人がいる
まあそれはしょうがないと
と無視することはできるんですかと
仏教の立場からはそう無視することはできないんですよ
大きい声で喋ることは役に立つ場合もあるし
たくさんの人がいるところでたくさんの人に喋らなくちゃいけない
その場合は大きい声で喋る
それは役に立ちますけど
まあ例えば こちらで我々まあ説法している
みんな静かでいる それでどなたか外から来て
誰かを呼ぶと そこでドアドアを開けて
ものすごいでっかい声で
もうもう天井も響くぐらい声で
田中さん ちょっとこっちへいらっしゃいと言っちゃうと
これえらい迷惑でしょうね
まあしょうがない その人の声はどうしてもでっかいだからと
いうふうにちょっと見逃すことも
見逃すこともなかなか難しいとは思います
仏教の立場は決してこのこれは癖だからっていうことを言い訳にしないでくださいと
気をつけなさいと なぜかというと
癖は善なら善化になるし
悪なら悪化になるんですよ
因果法則は避けられません
誰にも乗り越えられません
行為に結果はある これはもう絶対的な法則で
どうにもならない だから癖は悪だったら悪化になっちゃうし
善だったら善化にはなります
だから癖だからしょうがないという言い訳は我々やってますけど
仏教では成り立たないんですね
癖さえも気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
というわけで 道徳判断
癖にも必要なんです 生命の行為は貪瞋痴の感情に支配されると悪行為になる
一応 仏教の道徳判断というのは
この貪瞋痴 むさぼり 怒り
無知という 3つの感情は決まり手なんです
まだたくさんの感情はありますけど
全部この大きなカテゴリの 3つに入ります
むさぼりっていうのは好きという
好むという 執着的に欲しいという感情に入るカテゴリ
全部むさぼりというし
嫌やと怒りに関わるものは
嫉妬も怒りでしょうし
憎しみも怒りでしょうし
攻撃することも怒りでしょうし
何でもかんでも批判することも怒りでしょうしね
そうやってこの嫌というアプローチする感情っていうのは怒りで
無知っていうのはよく理解しないで
ただ単に行動する時なんですね
もう何でもいいんだからと
それももう第三者にはよく見えます
やっていることには何の理性も理屈も論理もないんですね
ただ単にやっていると
そういう貪瞋痴に支配されている行為はすべて悪なんですね
それで逆に不貪不瞋不痴という欲がない状態
怒りがない状態 無知がない状態
まあない状態といってもよろしいし
まあその方が理解しやすいんですよ
で ポジティブ的に考えるような無知がない状態は
ポジティブ的に考えると
すごい理性的で 物事をやらなくてはいけないんだからやる
ある理由があって 訳があって
論理があって行動を起こす
本人に何であんたこんなことしたんでしょうかというと
まあこういうわけで こういうわけで
こういう結果を目指してこういうことをしましたというふうにちゃんとした理解があるんですね
たとえ行動が間違っていても
行動は正しいか結果次第です
結果でわかるもんだからね
ですから この無知のポジティブの言葉はいくらかわかります
で むさぼりがない 怒りがないということは
まあそれぐらいで理解すればいいんじゃないかなと思います
で 癖として行う行為の場合も同じ法則なのです
だから 癖にしたっても
この癖が貪瞋痴か不貪不瞋不痴かということによって
良い癖にもなったりするし
悪い癖にもなったりするし
そこで問題は自分で知らないことなんですよ
例えば人を怒鳴っている場合は
自分が怒っているとはっきりわかっているんだからね
癖の場合はわからないんです
だからちょっと危ないんですよ
で まあ異論もあります
異論というのは まあ癖にも善悪あるんだよと言ってもね
そう言った途端 もう悪いことするなよという話もあるでしょうしね
癖は意志的に意図的に行うものではないでしょう
まあ別に意志的にわざとやっているものじゃないんでしょうに
強い意志が働いてないのに
善とか悪とか判断できるはずはありませんと
別に自分で意志が働かせてないんだから
これが善ですよ 悪ですよとそんな言えないんではないかという異論が立てられます
反射的に無意識的な行為だというべきものではありませんかと
それは異論なんですね
そういう異論が立てられます
癖にも善悪ありますよと
と言った途端 悪い癖は戒めなくちゃいけないということになってくるし
まあ大変ですね 自分でも知らないし
自分別にそんなことを考えてやっているわけでもないんだからね
だからそんなこと言っても困るんじゃないかなという反論なんです
で それにこれからずっと答えていきます
その反論に答えなんですね
今日の講義っていうのは
しょうがないではないんだと
煩悩っていうのは多重構造構成です
これなかなかこの仏教の心理学やらビダやら勉強しても
もう本当にこれが理解しにくいほど心の働きは複雑なんです
仏教では無意識という概念もないんですよ
概念もないんだけど 多重構成みたいな
これも現代的な言葉で
仏典で出てくる言葉じゃないんです
一概に貪瞋痴だといっても
我々は理解するのは意識的に感じる欲
怒りと無知です  私たち一般的に貪瞋痴
貪瞋痴というと まあ皆様方は自分の心にある意識に上がっている欲
怒り 無知は認識できますよ
だから怒りが 私は怒ってないんだぞということも言えるし
だからといって今怒ってないんだから
怒りのない人間でしょうか？と言えないでしょう
今欲がないんだからといって欲がない人間ですと言えないでしょう
今は頭しっかり動いてるんだから
今は無知がないと だから無知がない人ですかね
だから意識に上っただけではわからないんです
本当はそれにさえもそんなに気づいていないんですよ
欲がある時 全然欲やと気づかないんですね
怒っている時は 自分が怒っていると全然気づかないんですよ
それ終わってから気づくんですよ
その時怒っていたんだと
その時欲張っていたんだと
で 後で悩んだりするんですね
例えば儲かるんだぞと言って
何かすごいお金 もう何かって誰かにあげちゃってなくなった時はね
後から悩むんですね その時は欲張らなかった方がよかったんではない
今更ね もう終わってるんだから
その時怒らなかった方がいいんじゃないかなとかね
というふうに 人間というのはもう過去形では気づくんですけど
もう何の意味もないんですね
ことが終わってからわかっても
これは英語の諺がありますね
馬が逃げてから馬小屋に鍵をつけると
逃げてから鍵をつけたって馬がいないんだからね
だから人間というのは
その現在進行形でわからないんですね
怒りが出てくると 欲が出てくると
無知が出てくると もう感情的で頭がわからなくなっちゃって行動するんですよ
だからかなり罪を犯しちゃうし
失敗もする もし今自分が怒っている
今の瞬間で自分が欲張っている
今の瞬間で自分が嫉妬していると
今の瞬間で この現在進行形でわかるということは
これは仏教の人々以外はできません
そういう教えはないんです
他の哲学では 宗教では
それで仏教も勉強しただけで
勉強して ちょっとちょっと実践してみると
まあ一応気づく 気づかれるようになります
例えば皆様が実践しているヴィパッサナー実践とか
いくらか自分にそれも癖になってくると
この現在進行形で今欲がある
今怒っている 今無知ですとかね
今眠気があるとか 今落ち込んでいるとか
この現在進行形でわかるようになるんです
それも本物 心の中にある状況じゃなくて
この上に何て言いますか
感情が現れた時の話なんですね
だからヴィパッサナーの気づきのやり方で
自分の怒りに欲に気づいても
それでも足りませんよ
だからみんないろいろ質問するでしょうね
もうこの間怒って 自分が怒り
怒りでいたんですけど
なかなか怒りがなくなりましたと
怒りが出てくると怒り
怒りというんですけど
また怒りが出てくるのは
それはどういうわけかと
自分の気づきのやり方が間違っているんでしょうかとかね
あれこれ質問するんですね
だから本当のことは言えないし
その程度ではダメですよということなんです
知り尽くさないと それにはものすごい
さらにさらにさらに もう頑張らないとできなくなる
できないんです で 多重構成は続きます
意識に貪瞋痴が現れることは感情が起きたことなので
本人はあまり気づかない
自分の意識にも貪瞋痴の何か現れたと
それ感情なんですよ だから気づくはずがないんです
大体は 欲が出ちゃうと
もうそれにもう決まってる行動パターンをやってしまうんですね
美味しい食べ物を目の前にあると
つい手が出ちゃうというね
これが美味しいなと思った瞬間でも欲なんですね
そうなると その手が出てしまうんです
その時は気づかないんですよ
その時食べてしまって
あ 食べ過ぎになりましたとかね
自分がダイエット中でいたのにとかね
後で後悔したりする 癖の場合は
意識に上る 貪瞋痴は衝動にならないと思う
で 怒ったらその時 その相手に対して叱ったり殴ったりする
それが癖じゃないんですよ
自分でも知ってるんだから怒ってるんだと
ちょっと後でもわかりますからね
癖の場合は気づかないんですね
癖で起こっているならば
これもね しょっちゅうだからね
24時間だから 全然本人が気づかない
だからこれ違うと皆様瞑想でもして
怒りだ 欲だ 無知だとか
もう実況する 確認する
それとは違う 貪瞋痴なんです
癖になるのは だからお釈迦様の瞑想をやったんだから
癖が全部なくなったとか言うと
ちょっと甘すぎなんですね
かなり厳しいんです 癖の状況
状況は ちょっと難しいポイントなんですけど
少々考えるとわかると思います
癖っていうのは無意識的な行動です
だから その時自分が怒っているか
欲張っているかとわからないはずなんです
意識的な行動ではわかるんです
何かおかしいことを見たところで怒ってしまったと
その時本人にしても あなたはこういうことをやるんだから
私は怒っているんだよと
じゃあ意識あるんですよ
我々瞑想なんかで確認するのは
そういうよくわかる意識なんです
だから確認作業がすごく上手になってくると
微妙に心の動きも確認することができるようになります
表面的に現れる感情の下に煩悩のレイヤーです
だから表面的に上がってくる貪瞋痴の下にもう一つレイヤーがあります
それが癖を引き起こしちゃうんですね
だから意識の下にあるんですね
ブッダがアーサは流れるものだと説かれると
それはお釈迦様は特別な専門用語で
その同じ貪瞋痴で同じなんですけど
働き 違うんだから意識化にならないんだだから
もう勝手に起こるんだから
アーサワという言葉を言うんですね
流れるものって意味なんです
で アーサワはどれぐらいあるのかと
これがこれからこの癖の原因なんですね
癖はどうやって生まれてくるのかと
一応 4つ焦点で出てくるんです
1番目 カーマーサワ  心っていうのは刺激が欲しいんですよ
で 刺激っていうのはこのすごい具体的で
この目から耳から鼻から舌から体から入れる情報なんですね
で 心は刺激して回転するんですね
それから その入った情報について考えながらさらに刺激するんですよ
それがただ刺激が欲しいだけのことだから
それカーマーサワと言うんですね
で その衝動で何か行動が起こすんですよ
だから 人のカーマーサワ
どれぐらい どんな程度
どんなレベルであるのかということは個人差がありますけど
それに合わせていろんな刺激に入ったりする
まあ大体食べ物の場合
言えば大体いろんな人にものすごい好物っていうものがある
好物 好きな食べ物っていうのは
好きな食べ物は何ですか？好きな音楽は何ですか？とかね
好きな作家は誰ですか？とかね
自分が尊敬している人物は誰ですか？とか
よく聞くんでしょうにね
あんなのはなんで質問されるのかって
その人は何者かと理解したいとも思いますよ
例えば好きな食べ物は何ですか？と聞いても
世の中の人間 食べる食べ物は別にどうったことはないんだけど
なんでその中で一つ二つ選んで
これが好きな食べ物だとそう言うんですかね
その人がそれ食べると結構刺激を受けるんですよ
だからそれが好きな食べ物になってしまうんです
別なものを食べても そういう刺激は受けません
入りません そういう風に
好きな音楽は何ですか？音楽を言えば音楽は音楽なんですけど
好きなジャンルがありますね
その好きな歌手とか好きなジャンルの音楽と聞くと
かなりもう刺激を受けて興奮するんです
だから私たちは知らないんですよ
なんで自分がこの音楽好きですか？と
なんでこの食べ物を好物ですか？と
なんでこういうこういう人のことは好きですか？と
知らないでしょ それがカーマーサがあるんだから
そこから現れてくるだけ
だから貪瞋痴として見えるんじゃないんですね
私はロック音楽好きやとか
ロック音楽の中でも何々さん
何々さんが好きやとかいう風になるだけ
私に欲があるんだということにはならないんです
ある人は私はまあ チョコレートケーキ好きやというと
あるいはメロンは大好きですよというと
これただの欲なんですけど
そういう場合はこれが欲ですということをわかるよりは
まあしょうがないんだと
他のものは食べられないんだと
他のケーキは食べられませんと
チョコレートケーキなら食べられますということになる
それでカーマーサということになる
2番目はババーサ 存在欲ですね
死にたくないという気持ちですね
これ すべての生命にあるんですね
死にたくはないんだと
それで死にたくないために
そのその個人がいろいろ行動する
無意識的に 次にディッターサ
見解にとらわれること
これすごく説明難しいんですけどね
心のこれ認識過程の問題で
心っていうのは あるということしか認識できないんですよ
これ大変なことで 実際は物事はあるというわけじゃないんです
で 我々にはあるというふうにしか認識できない
だから あの人がいる この人がいるというふうに我々は認識しているんです
それでないということは
まあ推測で で認識する
それは実感ではないんですね
例えば まあ今日は桜の花はないですね
それがあることを頭経験あるんだから
それから推測するんですね
そのある状態はないと
時々人を見て あんたよく変わりましたというでしょうに
どうやってそれ言うんですかね
昔のことを昔はその人会った
今も同じ人がいる 昔の人と今の人と比較すると同一じゃないんですね
だから変わったと言うんです
しかし 変わる過程はわからないんです
すべて瞬間瞬間変わっているんですよ
瞬間変わっているんだから
すべて一時的な状態であって
本物じゃないんです 例えば
舞台の上で誰かが侍の役をやっているんだとかね
王様の役をやっているんだとかね
お侍のなんとか役やってるんだからといって
それは本物じゃないでしょうに
一時的なことでしょう
で その時間で その人間がその舞台の上でその役を演じるしか方法もないんです
でも舞台を降りたら別な役
舞台で時間変わるとまた役が変わる
だから一コマだけ見て
これがこの人やと考えるのは間違いでしょうし
誰もそういうことをしないでしょうに
舞台の上で人を殺す場面がある
それを見て あ この人は人殺しやと全然思わないんです
で そういう時はもう変わってるんだということは考えてないんだけど
あまりそんなに執着はしないんですが
全てのものはそういうふうに一時的な存在であって
本物の存在というわけじゃないんです
本物でないんですよ いずれも一時的な存在だから
本来の姿ということはありません
なのに 我々にはその無常っていうことはわからないんです
頭はそこまで強くないんですよ
心は 心に何か情報がぶん殴られたら
ぶつけたらあるとすぐ認識する
次にまた情報がぶつけたら
あ またそれもあるというふうに認識する
だから 世の中の人間の考え方の九十九パーセントあるという考え方なんです
例えば人間に魂があると言ってるでしょう
よくいうのこのこと言うこと
何の証拠もないでしょ
変わらない魂があるというならば
ただ単に今の瞬間に自分がいるという実感があるんですよ
前の瞬間でも自分がいたという実感がある
実感 全部つなげて並べて推測するんです
故に私がいると 我は思う
故に我がいると という単純な推測結論するんですね
これっていうのは見解という大きな間違いなんです
何かにしがみつく まあ一パーセントの人々はかなりもうないということに定着する
あれもこれも何でもないんだと
道徳の意味 そんな何にもないんだと
善も悪もそんなのあるわけないんだと
何だかんだもないないないと否定する
教無主義みたいな状態になる
そういうふうに何かを認識して
それにしがみつく それは正しいと思う
そこがこの阿蘇の三番目なんですね
みんなにありますよ ない人はいません
だから我々はすごい 例えば私が見たんだから
私は聞いたんだからとすごい胸張るでしょうに
あんたは聞いたっていても
それは違いますよと言っちゃうとすごく怒るんですよ
あんた見たんだからといって
誰が信じるんですかと
違いますよと言っちゃうと相手が怒るんですよ
なんで怒るんですかね
見解なんです 私が認識ものはその通りであると
違うはずがないんだと
自分が何か食べる これが美味しいですと
なぜなら私は食べたんだからと
他の人は これは本当にすごいまずい食べ物やと言うと
もう気が立つんですよ
だから自分が知る世界正しいと
何かの見解にしがみつく
まだ思想体系的にもいろいろ仏教では人間何を考えられるのかっていうことはね
人間に可能な範囲考えるね
範囲のものは一応いろいろ項目を作ってあります
で これが人間に考えられる範囲の話だから
今日はもう説明しないよ
これ難しいんです  経典を勉強するとか
そういうまあ 専門的にやるとき以外はちょっと説明できないんです
で 世間で簡単に言えば
例えばこの何でしたっけ？神様がいるとかね
人間には魂があるとか
そういうふうに何か信じ込んでしまえば
それで考えるものは それに基づいて考えるんです
神様がいると思っている人々は
あらゆるものを考えますよ
あらゆる情報を調べるんだけど
それは神様がいるということはいかに証明するのかということなんです
だから霊魂がある 魂があるといって
まあ西洋のね 原始的な思考の世界でね
まあものすごいしがみ込んで
武力持ってるんだからね
強引に人々に他人に押し付けたりしてやっていた時代で
まあそんな強引にやらなくたっても
哲学的にそれ証明できないんではないかといって
ある人が我は思う 故に我がいると
えらいことを発見したような感じで
何のことも発見してないんですけど
これでヨーロッパは大騒ぎ
ただの馬鹿者なんですけど
それによってヨーロッパは大騒ぎで
それで哲学は始まりましたとかね
何のこともないんですけども
それで一体的な私がいるかというと
思うことっていうのはもうもう瞬時に変わるでしょうに
ちょっと前に思ったことは今は全然思わないでしょうに １０
年前には結婚した相手がすごい美人やと思っていたんですけど １０
年経ったらそう思ってないでしょうに
だから思うことはもう瞬間に変わりますのに
ということは 我が思う
しかし私がいないという話でしょ
我は思う しかし我がないと言えばよかったのに
それは何かでものすごいもう子供みたいなことを言うんですよ
だっているんじゃないかという感じで
子供ですよ そんなこと言うの
でもなんでそこがすごい偉大なる哲学者になったと
革命的なことを言ったとなったのは
そういうディッキがあるんだからね
みんなに 癖ですよ それが
神がいる 神が永遠の命を我々には授けてくれたというディッキがあって
そこから物事を見るんですね
だから自由な思想にはならないんです
仏教でも同じですよ いろいろ宗派があるんだから
各宗派の方々は私の話を聞くと
自分の宗旨の教えという
その角度から見るんですよ
だから納得したと言っても
それ私が言ったことではありませんよ
自分の考え方に合いましたと
だから納得しました 全然理解してないんだから
自分の考え方に合っただけで正しいわけないでしょうに
だったら話聞く必要ないでしょうに
初めからもう己の思考が正しいということだから
話聞くなよということで
そちらに矛盾があるんですよ
どんな人でもそうでしょう
我々の考えている考え方に賛成的な話を聞くと
えらい納得するんですよ
それでよく新しいものを勉強したと
いわゆる錯覚まで起こすんですよ
自分の意見にまるっきり正反対なことに
もうなんだこれとかね
あの本おかしいと あの人の話はもうおかしいと
そうやって攻撃までする
それで知識人にはなりません
だから誰も知識人ではありませんよ
このディッターが悪限りは
大変なことなんです ものすごい複雑で
非常に人間の理解範囲は一応超えているところなんです
争いの話になってくると
私たちにできますかね
自分の気持ちにまるっきり逆らう
全く正反対の人の話を聞いたり
理解したりすること できない
来ないでしょうに そういうところに行かないでしょう
そこはすごい正直 イスラム教は他宗教の話は絶対聞くなよと
で 決まりつけている だからコーランの言うことのみが正しいと
のみが正しいと言っちゃうと
間違ったことを勉強するということは
神を侮辱することになるんです
それで世界中バカもんたちが現れてくるんです
キリスト教はそれをそれほど格好悪くはないんですけどね
それは昔 そうえらいかっこ悪かったんですけど
戦争したり戦争したりね
イスラム教とものすごいやりとり
戦争を戦ったりとかね
で 後でまあ いくらか まあまとめにはなりましたし
今はそれほどかっこ悪くはないんだけど
やっぱりそれでもいろんな原理主義とかね
まあまああちこちで現れたりはする
だから私たちは人の話を聞くっていうことは
最初からもう同じ考え方を持ってるんだから
似ている考え方を持ってるんだからなんですね
だから本にしたっても
これであなたの才能が抜群に発揮できるんだとかね
これでもたった 20 分で最高に幸せになるんだとか
そういう本で出すと もうもう必ずものすごいもうヒットするんです
よくいいの 新しいことを勉強しましたとかね
なんとかの法則勉強しますとか言うんだけど
何も勉強してないんです
自分の見解を正当化する
ものをやっただけ  4番目のアーサがアヴィッジャーアーサというんですね
アヴィッジャー無明 だからこれが基本的なアーサで流れるもので
心はもともと能力ないんですよ
ものを知る能力がないんです
あるということを知るんだから
それ自体間違いなんです
で わかりやすい例で 例えば滝
噴水あるでしょ あるんじゃないんですよ
川とか滝とかね 瞬間たりとも止まることなく流れて別のもになっていくでしょうに
それは見えません  1時間じーっと見ていても
私は 1時間なんとか滝を見たんだ
楽しかったんだとかね
マイナスイオンはいっぱい吸いましたとかね
それでマイナスイオンを吸うとすごい気分が良くなるんだと
そこはすごい暗示なんですよ
だから自分がいい気分になりたい
まずそれは自分のディッティなんです
誰かがマイナスイオンをいっぱい吸ったら
すごいもう気分が穏やかになるんだよと
なるほど 私も気分が穏やかになりたいんだから
このマイナスイオンちょうだいと
と これは滝があるところにありますよと
あ そうか言って そちらに走るんです
で そこで 1時間ぐらいいて
やっぱりマイナスイオンはさすが素晴らしいやと言う
よくわかったような 昔からもあったんだから
なんで昔からそれ発見していなかったんですかね
滝のそばにいるとすごい気分が穏やかになるんだと
もう一つ言います もうこれから研究するだろうと思いますけどね
私たち人間も動物もどうかわからないんだけど
植物に惹かれるんですよ
もし家がなかったら どこかの木の下に行くんです
これわからないでしょ
理由は 全く平らなところで
草もないところで はあ
気分がいい ここに座りましょうってそんな気分になりません
例えばちょっとした まあこれぐらいの面積でもよろしいんですけど
もう砂利で埋め尽くす
歩いたい気分にもなりません
で こちら芝で埋め尽くして
あちらこちらちょっとちょっと砂利できれいに作って
腰をかけられるようにしておいて
腰をかけるんです 砂利の上に
普段は歩きたくもないんだけど
なぜかで周りが芝だからなんです
花も植えてあるんだからなんです
それで大きな公園で 例えば一本の大きな木があると
みんな遊びに行って ボール遊びやらいろんなことを遊んだりして
その時は交換が必要なんですけど
では 弁当食べようと思っちゃうと
みんなあの木のところに行くんですよ
あちらに行って弁当食べようと
あれって何ですかね とにかく樹木っていうのは生命を自分のところに引き寄せるんですよ
こっちおいでよと あるいは逆に
我々は安全を期待して
親のところに子供が走るような感じで
例えば小さな子供はあちこち遊んでいたっても
遊んでいながらまたずっと走って親の体にぶら下がっちゃって
また出て行って遊んじゃうんですね
だから親のところに行ったり来たりしないと不安なんです
そういう感じで 私たちは植物あるところに行くんです
だからこれから研究するんですよ
植物は持っている この引力って何なのかとかね
あ こういうエネルギーが持ってるんだとかね
だからそこをこのもう樹木のもうそのエネルギーが体に入ると
随分穏やかに気分になるんだぞと言っちゃうと
みんなそこでよく分かったいと言って
またさらに木の下に走ろうとする
昔からやっていることなんですけどね
水が流れる音は好きっていうことは昔からあったんだけどね
そこで新しい発見でもなんでもないんです
我々の力でそれに飛び込む
だから私はわざと植物のことはまだまだ研究していないんだからね
それはマイナスイオンか何か発見するでしょうね
どうということはないんです
それはディッターサヴァで
まあアヴィッジャサヴァの説明
ちょっとまたもう元に戻ってしまったんですけどね
アヴィッジャサヴァっていうのは
我々にはあるということは認識できないんだから
まあ基本的な我々の弱みなんです
動いているということは認識できないようになっています
だから ちょっと認識次元を超えないと
見えるもの 聞こえるものだけ聞くんで
聞いたり見たりするんじゃなくて
もうちょっと認識のやりとりをちょっと育ててもらわないと無常は見えないんです
だからアヴィッジャサヴァっていうものがあるんです
輪廻する生命には欠かせない精神的な働きです
だから我々にはこの 4つは欠かせないんですよ
だって刺激なかったら生きていられないでしょうに
大体刺激がなくなるとみんな何するのかというと寝ちゃうでしょ
だったら刺激が それって何ですかね
講演は面白くないと思っちゃうと
もうすぐ寝るんです 面白くないということは
この話を聞いても刺激は入らないということなんです
寝るということが刺激なんです
だから寝ることを喜んでいるんです
なんて幸せかなと だから誰でも面白くないんだから寝るぞというのも同じやり方で
これカーマーサヴァなんですけど
それも 1番目 カーマーサヴァにありますけど
だから我々にとってはなかなか欠かせないものなんですね
猫も人が遊んでくれるんだったら遊んで
もうでないとすぐ寝ると
で カーマーサヴァなんですね
だからそういう生き方をみんなやっているんです
で アーサヴァですから
これなかなか気づかないレベルなんですよ
私の説明も意識化した時の話なんです
説法したっても この意識化した時のことしか説法もできません
だって相手にわからないんだから
無意識的にあるところはなかなか出てこないんです
無意識的には我々にはあるということしか知りませんし
で 顕界に束縛されているし
で 刺激に依存しているしね
死にたくはないし 死にたくはないってことはずっとあるんだけど
病気になったり事故を起こしたりする時
意識化するでしょうに
何も病気もなく すごい健康で安全に生きていると
死にたくない死にたくと思わないんですよ
だから私は死にたくないというアーサヴァがあるんだぞと誰も気づかないんです
これで死にかけているとわかるんですよ
人がいない もう暗いところで一人で歩く時とかね
ちょっと怖くなったりする
その時 あのバーワーサヴァが意識レベルに上がるんです
意識レベルに上がったらアーサヴァと言わないんです
もう仕事変わったんです
日本語でアーサヴァがこのロになっています
で サンスクリット語のあに
これゆも書かなくちゃいけないんですけど
スッスという この これ動詞の語幹なんですね
で スルっていうのは流れるっていうことで
そのサンスクリット語の単語で意味を取ってるんです
日本訳では漢文も同じくなっているんです
だからわざと自分が取った意味が正しいと一生懸命説明するんです
原文で本当にお釈迦様が何を考えたか
それはどうでもいいんです
だってサンスクリット語でこうではないかということで
別にお釈迦様がサンスクリット語を喋ったわけじゃないんです
で 漏れる場合は流れが外から心の中に漏れるという意味になります
漏れるという場合は やっぱり外から中へ漏れるんですよ
中から外へ漏れるということも言えるわけよ
言えますけどね だから清らかな心に外からいろいろ欲やら
存在欲やらね 現れてくるんだと
例えば殺されかけたところで
外の原因だから このアースが荒技だと
死にたくないというね
殺されかかなかったら全然私は心はそんな煩悩がないんだぞと
ということになっちゃうんです
車ですごい気分よく行ってる時は
突然他の人が車を自分の差しにいきなり出したところで
いきなりびっくりしちゃって
ブレーキをかけちゃって
それで心臓はもうドキドキしちゃう
はっ やっと助かったと
あの瞬間で危ない 死に死ぬかもというふうな
すごい恐怖感が出てくる
それはバワーサワなんですね
だからバワーサワはアーサワなんかは外から出てくるもんじゃないかなというふうに思っちゃいますけど
本当は違います それがよくわかりやすい日常的な心の機能ですよ
外から漏れるということ
そしたら中に漏れるということはわかりやすいんですよ
皆様は今は別に興味も何もないんだけど
こちらにすごい綺麗に
あのいけた花瓶とかね
花とか持ってきて置いておくと見るでしょう
見て あ 綺麗だとなんて綺麗な花だ
その瞬間で思うでしょうね
その場合は欲が生まれたでしょうに
楽しくなったでしょうに
だから今まで全然興味はなかったのに
眠くなっていたのに そこで綺麗な花の花瓶を持ってくると
すぐまた心が回転しちゃって
ああ 綺麗な花だとか だからそこはわかりやすいんですよ
今全然興味ないんだけど
誰かがこちらの中で歌でも歌でも始めたら
みんないきなりもう目が覚めて興奮しちゃって
元気になって それを聞くでしょうに
だから踊ろう 歌おうという欲が外から現れたっていうことはね
わかりやすいんです そんな話は
飴で食べる 食べる気がなくても
自分の好物 ごちそうが誰か持ってくると
はい どうぞと言うと やっぱり欲が出てきますよ
そのレベル程度だったらわかりやすい
煩悩は外から流れるというところは
パーリ仏教では中から
下から湧き上がるという意味も使います
パーリ語のアーサワの場合は
煩悩が中から外 心の中から下からと言ったって
もうおなじみですけどね
心の中から湧き上がる
いわゆる外へ漏れる 漏れるといっても意味は 2つあるんですよ
雨 雨漏る場合は中へ漏る
ちょっと割れ目が入ってる瓶に水を入れちゃうと外へ漏れる
です それで我々は自分の心を認識するのは意識レベルだけ
そこで美しい花を見ると
意識レベルで欲が現れてくる
楽しみが現れてくる それで外から汚れたことになる
心の無意識の中から愛想が上がってくると
また心の中に欲が現れるんです
だから心というものがあって
外から光を当てるか 下から光を当てるか
当てるかということで
あるいは赤い光 外から当てると赤くなって見える
下から当ててみると また赤くなって見えるような感じで
心がどちら側からでも煩悩を作って汚れるんです
アーソーの意味はそういう意味が 2つあります
欲 怒りなどは必ずしも外の情報に触れるから起こるのではありません
欲 怒りなどが自然に心の中から湧き上がって機能する場合もあります
外の原因は何もないんだけど
怒っている 外の原因は何もないんだけど
欲張っているとかね ことはよくあります
ただ心が勝手に その場合は中から湧き上がっているんです
その場合は本人には自覚がないんです
それが癖の世界なんです
美しい人を見て欲しくなったということは癖じゃないんです
この美しい方は調子に乗るんじゃないよと
このバカと言っちゃうと欲が消えますからね
しかし 心の中から痩せた女性の方が大好きやという考え方だったら
そう簡単には消えないはずなんで
それは癖の世界で あんまり説明しなくてもわかるでしょう
で  2つ目の働きは癖に関係があるのです
2つ目  2番目の働きは癖の世界です
だから日本仏教で説明するところは癖の説明がありません
それは誰にでもわかる説明なんです
で さらに阿僧について
感情が心の底から湧き上がってくると
本人にはそう簡単に管理できません
そう簡単じゃないんです
この犯罪なんかはね あの
まあそっちをやると 例えばこの
何でしたっけ このアメリカは厳しい
子供に対する犯罪とかね
性犯罪とかね それで厳しい罰を与えて
もう 10年  20年 もう刑務所に入れてあって
また外へ出しても また同じことをやっちゃうんです
やめられないんですよ
例えば子供に対する性的な犯罪を起こした人が
あれ もうたまたま子供がいたんだからやったんだよということじゃないんです
一人でいる時でも探しちゃうんですね
で 心は変えられません
そういうふうに この人間にはいろいろ
まあそれは悪例なんですけど
いい例も同じで まあで
背が高い女性の方が好みやとかね
まあおっぱいない方がすごい好きやとかね
まあいろいろありますけど
みんな言うの反対なんですけど
まあで まあおっぱいが大きい方がいいと思って
大きい人はいませんだからね
もうない方がいいと言った方がかなり儲かりますけど
でもその癖変えられませんでしょうね
だから中から現れる阿僧が癖で大変な厄介なものなんです
原因は外にある場合は
その場から離れれば済みますが
内から現れると逃げ場はありませんよ
なんかみんなすっごい性格悪くて
もうだらしなくて キャーキャーワイワイとやっているところでいると
自分がすっごく機嫌が悪くなるんだと
その場合は心が汚れたんですよ
外からなんです 別のところに行けばいいんですよ
簡単です どうしても食べ物に目がなくて
もうつい食べちゃうんだったら
食べ物を置いておかなきゃいいんですよ
解決します しかし これが原因
心にある場合はどうにもならない
仏教ではこの戒を守ることで
この戒律ですね 戒を守ることで外来の争いを妨げるし
瞑想実践でうちの心の中の争いを妨げる
なくすと でお釈迦様は実践を 2つ教えているんですね
戒律を守ることで 外の世界から心を守ってくれる
汚れないようにしてくれる
瞑想を実践することによって
中から湧き上がってくる争いを管理するんです
で 争いの働きは一応図にしてみたんですね
で で これは心というもので
心はどうせギザギザだからね
まあ線では書けないんですね
例えば外から情報 A が入ると怒っちゃうし
外から情報 B が入る 欲張っちゃうし
外から情報 B が入ると怒るし
外から情報C まあいい加減に書いたもんだから
別に何でもいいんだよ
こっちらへんは こういう情報が入ると無知になると
まあいろいろ情報の種類によって心が反応を起こすんですね
貪瞋痴の反応 だからこの A という情報を与えなきゃ
こういう風な心が生まれないんです
これは阿僧祇の牢の外の働きなんです
で ここら辺カットすればいいんです
これ 何か見るものだったら見なきゃいいんです
何か見たところで情報 A
美しいものを見た それで欲が現れたと
だったら美しいものを見ないことにする
そうすると欲が現れないんです
でもそれで心が綺麗になったわけじゃないんですよ
で  2番目の内面 うちの原因はこうなるんですね
心が勝手に無地で作ったり
怒り作ったり 欲作ったりする
もう勝手に 外の情報はこんな感じで
もうバラバラバラバラいろんな情報があるんですよ
この外のあらゆる情報に関係なく
こちらはこういうふうなパターンで反応を起こす
その場合は先に欲があるんですよ
先に欲があって 心がこの無数の情報の中で適切な情報を探すんですね
欲が現れるとの青いものでしたから
こういうものを探しちゃうんですね
でしたっけ？覚えてない
あ そうですね だから こういうこういう情報はわざと探すんですよ
あるいはこういう情報であろうとも
こんなものやと思っちゃうんです
自分に欲があると もう悪い人間なのに
それそれでもいいんじゃないかと思っちゃうんです
自分が好きになった人だったら
その人に騙されている
あんたはこの間騙されたんではないか 10
万円にと まあまあ それぐらいのことどうったことないと平気なんですよ
騙されたんだから もう好きになってはあかんでしょうに
やっぱり心の中が欲があると
そうはうまくいかないんです
わざと情報まで ようとする
まあそんな騙されたってことじゃないんだよと何とか言うんですね
だからこれが癖に関する働きなんです
癖っていうのは 煩悩が中から刺激して貪瞋痴作っちゃうんです
これで終わらない 癖の原因はさらにあるんですね
心の潜在的働き 煩悩が潜在的にも働く
まあ潜在っていうのはね
寝ているんだということでね
本人にはこの働きの発見はほとんど無理なのです
まあ寝ている煩悩だからもう機能しない
だから発見できません
しかし 様々な感情が意識化する頻度をチェックすると
なんとか推測できます
それを瞑想する人にしかできないんです
自分がどんな風に心が動いているのかと
この頻度があるんですよ
どれぐらい怒るのか どれぐらいの欲張っているのかとかね
例えば怒りが自然に現れるのか
あるいはわざとあえて考えて怒っているのか
欲が自然に現れるのか
あるいはいろんなことをわざわざと考えて欲が作っているのかとかね
この頻度があるんですね
それは瞑想で心を観察していくと
これ頻度が見えてくると
潜在的な煩悩はどこら辺
どこら辺強いのかとわかるんです
潜在的な煩悩の方が怒りが強いんだったら
もう大体怒りが現れる頻度が多いんですね
欲が多いんだったら 欲が現れる頻度が多いんですね
それも大雑把で微妙ですよ
欲にもいろいろ種類がある
怒りにもいろいろ種類がある
無知にもいろいろ種類がある
とにかく潜在煩悩 無意識煩悩っていうのはもうあのわかりにくい
そういう推測しかできません
潜在的な働きには 過去生からの経験も多大な影響を与える
そこで今 すごい自分が欲張りの性格やというと
今世の原因ではなくて
過去生もあるんですよ
だから人が生まれると大体性格はもうできているんです
それは嘘やと思うならば
動物を見てください ペットとかね
すごい子供の時 買ってみてください
2 3匹ぐらい 全く性格違うんです
生まれる時はもうセットして
それが因果法則だから
過去生で積み込まれた
まあ刷り込まれたものなんですね
これが潜在的になっちゃって
もうどんどんどんどん湧き上がってくる
湧き上がったらわかるんだけど
湧き上がらないで寝ている状態のことはわからないんですね
だから潰さなくちゃいけないのは潜在的な煩悩なんですけど
なかなかそちらにアクセスできないんですよ
我々はヴィパッサナー瞑想でずっとアクセスするのは意識の煩悩なんです
無意識の煩悩にアクセスしなくちゃいけないんです
だからそれは瞑想のレベルがね
結構上がってもらわないとできないんです
とにかく我々の癖と性格には過去の原因もあります
それで終わらない またアーサヤというものもあります
まあここら辺は日本仏教
大乗仏教になってくると
ない あまり説明はないんですけど
これは自称では この何でしたっけ？よりどころ
よりどころにする煩悩という
あるものは我々はよりどころにしているんですね
同じ煩悩なんですよ これ
あの智慧の説明しているテキストがありまして
えーと 何でしたっけ あれは
パティサンビダーマッカという本がありまして
三蔵経の中に入っている本で
で 説明はあります 心の煩悩
汚れを示す言葉ですが
アーサヤという場合は
心の向き 傾向性 癖を意味します
そこはお釈迦様 アーサヤという言葉で言っているんです
これの説明はすごい面白い説明なんです
1番目は自分の存在を肯定的に見るか
否定的に見るかっていうこと
これ ババディッテニッシタあるいはイバディッテニッシタっていう風に書いてます
これはどうやってあそうかというのかというと
あせとあさえ あさえっていうのは
こうやってよくもう頼りにして支えにして
いるっていうことで 例えば魚釣りやってる時は
岸の方にしっかりと腰をかけて釣り竿を持っているんですね
それで地面があさえなんです
例えば 小さなボートに乗って大きな魚を釣ろうとしちゃうと
あさえが弱いんだだから溺れちゃうんですよ
だからあさえの方がしっかりしないとよりどころが
この場合はもうダメなもん
煩悩の世界なんですけどね
時々人々がいるんですよ
もうものすごい存在欲で
とにかく生き続けたいと風に派手に見える
まあ家は掃除 洗濯は欠かせないわ
いつでも綺麗にするわ
もうしっかり三食は食べるわ
もう毎日ちゃんと欠かさず運動するわとかね
この人は結構生きることに執着しているんだと
健康に長生きすることにはえらい執着しているんだと
即時には見える しかし
あさえっていうのはそういうことじゃないんですよ
この人は表面的にはえらいしっかりもんなんですけど
まるっきり生きることに無関心やと
いつ死んだってもどうったことないへっちゃらやと思ってる
思ってる性格やと これ発見しなくちゃいけないんですよ
しかし これが他人にも本人にも発見できないんです
でも時々我々世界でよく使うんですよね
時々 もう後で説明します
怒りの場合はね これは存在欲に対して
2番目はカーマ カーマガルカ
カーマあせ カーマガルカ
カーマ欲を重く思う 思っていることより土台にしている
カーマあせ カーマ欲を支えにしている
反対はネッカンマガルカ
ネッカンマーセ ネッカンマっていうのは離れる
刺激から離れるということで
欲から離れるということで
で 五欲に依存するか 五欲から離れることに興味あるかっていう 2つなんですよ
で ごく普通に美味しいものを食べて
例えばブッダの時代でいたんですよ
かなり贅沢する リッチな様息やら
で 贅沢する人々いたんですよ
全然自分の日常の生活習慣は変えません
しかし 真剣にブッダの教えを聞いて理解して
瞑想もして 悟りまでもう再起ですからね
阿羅漢までいかないんですけど
悟りまで開いている 悟っているのに何の変わりもない
今までやっていることを全部やっている
遊んでいるんですね そうすると
外の世界 あの人はブッダの話したり
ちょっとちょこちょこと瞑想なんかやったりするんだけど
何にも変わってないんですよと
あんなのはインチキやとかね
言うかもしれませんだけど
お釈迦様は知っています
あの人は見た目では全然欲張ってやってますけど
心の中では欲から離れているんだと
だからそこはアーサという世界なんですね
見た目で判断しない あるいは表面的にも欲張りで
心の中土台になっているところも欲だったら
その人は欲のアーサであると
欲に依存しているんだと
だからそこら辺は皆様にはあまり興味はあっても興味ではなくてね
それほど関係ないんですよ
これが お釈迦様には大変大事な能力で
人々に瞑想し どうやらいろんなことを教えたりする場合は
その能力はすごく必要なんです
表面では判断しないということ
ゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャ愚痴で言ったってもね
心を底を見てみるんです
口では私のところに来た方々
みんなまあ若者以外はね
すぐぜひ悟りたいという
私から誰かが皆様ではなくて
他の人が話を聞くと 本当ですか？と
あのグループは真剣だ
とんでもないかと私は言うでしょう
一人も興味がないんだと
真理を発見する興味は
心の底の問題 心の底にその興味があると
たちまち 若い人々が来ると
もうどうせ若者だからね
何もわからないんですね
一応 そこで頭は元気でしょうし
体も元気でしょうし いきなり私は強引にこの面白さ
興味っていうのはこの埋めてあげるんです
面白いんだから ちょっと試しに挑戦してみなさいと
結構進んじゃうんですね
その場合 だから若い時は正義の味方みたいなね
いいことをしたいんだとかね
そういう正直なところあるんですよ
社会人になってくると
もうとんでもない悪人になるんです
自分のことしか考えません
若者って善人というわけじゃなくても
親が食べさせているんだから
もう心配することはないんですね
だから世直ししようではないかとか
偉そうなことを言っています
自分で生計を立てることになってくると
あの正義の味方はひとかけらもなく消える
だからまあ まだまだ親に依存している若者が来ると
仏教を教えるのは早いんです
だからそういう悪いアーサがまだ機能しないんです
それから ビャーパーダガルク
ビャーパーダーセ あるいはアッビャーパーダガルク
アッビャーパーダーセという 3番目
ビャーパーダというのは瞋恚
ものすごい怒りですね
で 強烈な怒りが心にあって
世の中にものすごい世直しに行く人々がいますよ
衝動は怒り ボランティアやる
いろんなもう赤十字に入っちゃり
あれこれやっても必死でやるんだけど
衝動は怒り 表面でではわかりません
あるいは ある人々はものすごい瞋恚で
仏さんみたいに不戦さんみたいに人を殺すことしか考えません
その場合は 心の中も外も同じ
時々外と中は正反対の時もあります
で 仏教の世界で 特に瞑想指導したりする場合は
心にあるこの正反対のところが
チェックしなくちゃいけないんですよ
なぜかというと 裏にある表にあることっていうのはどうってことないんです
ある人がもうずっと私に言っていたんだから
興味ないんだと 瞑想なんかにはと
だから話は話はもう論理的で
決めてると いうことで
瞑想なんか悟りなんかもう嫌やという態度で
すごい正直で 最初にその人は堂々とそれを言った途端
私の心の中にえらい正直なもんやと
すごい映しちゃったんですね
本音を言うんだと もう本音を言うんだったら
もうもう問題ないと 私はその場で言っても問題ないと
瞑想しなくていいやと
あんたは嫌だから だから頭で理解したいでしょ
じゃあ頭で理解してくださいと
でも その人はものすごい成長したんです
まあ亡くなりましたけど
一回も瞑想会に来なかったんですよ
でも必死で調べて理解して
亡くなるところはまあなんとかなんとか言って亡くなっちゃったんですけどね
私はもう生きる目的に達しましたと
だから誰も心配する必要もないですよ
何もないんだと そういう一言葉を残して亡くなられるんだからね
だからもう頑張る人はいるんだけど
私に抗議した人が成功して
一生懸命拝んでやろうと思っている人は全然微妙にでも前に進まないっていうことは
それは心の裏と表の問題なんですね
本人が隠しているつもりもないんですけど
まあしょうがないんですよ
隠せませんけどね これは怒りの問題で
ものすごく怒っているんだけど
心底優しい人もいるし
で 時々学校の先生たちとかね
ものすごい鬼でも ちょっとしたことに怒鳴ったり
怒ったり もうすごい厳しい
しかし 子供たちのことは我が子のように心配する
また ある先生たちがみんな子供たちの機嫌を取ってあげて
楽しませてあげて すごい人気者になる
しかし 心の中はこの連中はもう一応ちょっと機嫌を取ってあげればまあいいや
それぐらいで 俺も仕事だからねという態度なんですよ
子供に対して親切じゃないんです
具体的な例で言えばね
あの 皆様 あのハリーポッターの映画見たことがありますかね
あれは子供の世界ですけどね
そちらにある先生がいるんですね
という 見る限り 変な悪いことをやっているような感じで
嫌味 嫌がらせとかね でも微妙に子供たちをもうしっかり管理するんです
でもやることは全部嫌がらせな
嫌がらせ 子供のことをものすごく嫌がって怒ってるようなこと言うと
全然子供のことを心配しているということをひとかけらも見せない
ハリー・ポッターに対しては
もう何か言ったらとんでもないことを言って怒鳴りつける
あんた何様のつもりで思ってるんですかと
でも あれでその子供たちをきちんとこの育てているんですよ
だからそこはもうまあ
すごい ものすごい研究して考えて書いてる
バカバカらしい本のように聞こえますけど
かなり研究して書いてるもので
小説でね そこら辺は このいろんな先生たちの過去をね
で計算してみるんですね
学長のダンブルドアでいえば
どちらかというと もう子供と一緒にいたずらやりましょうというぐらいの感じで
学長だからできないっていうか
お前ら勝手にやれ それ知らんぞという態度を取るんですね
それと全く違う態度をとる
だから まあそれはもう作った物語だからね
あまりこの人生の例にはなりませんだけど
まあ似ている人々っていうのは世の中でいくらでもいるんですよ
口ではうるさいんだけどね
あの 私は日本の大学に入った時でもね
坂井徳源という禅の坊主がいて
教授でみんな悪口を言うんですね
誰とも喋れない 何か言っても先生だから
そんな態度なんですね
何か まあこういう本は今読んでますけど
私は興味ないね 何者のかとみんな悪口言ってますよ
だから私もこの人本当に性格悪いのかと
言うとそうじゃないんです
誰にも近寄らない すごい頑固でわがままでいい加減という役を演じてみんな脅してるんです
あんなわがまま いい加減勉強もしないだらしない
あの連中も最悪だからね
もう見た限り あの学部の学生たちっていうのはね
とんでもないんですよ
でも どんな悪ガキでも坂井徳源さんの授業ではじーっと真面目にいるんです
授業中 ちょっとでも音を立てたら
お前立ちなさい このバカって言うんで平気で
すごいきつい きつい失礼な言葉しか使わない
敬語とか大学で使う単語とかない
全部ものすごい悪い品のない言葉で
でも面白いことは あんな体格でっかい男たちはね
何のことなくもう反論できん
じっと立つんです これ
小学校学校じゃないんだけどね
大学なんですけど 立ってるんですよ
だからそこ まあ私は分野はそんな違うし
同じ分野でしたけど あの考え方とはもうはるかに私の研究分野が変わっていたんだからね
当てにならなそうという感じで
まああまり近寄らなかったんですけど
で でも授業なんか聞いてると
ある一回 ちょっと二 三分間ではなくて
まあほんの少々遅れてきて
すごい怒鳴りつけて 何様のつもりですか？立て
立たせちゃったんです
その男はもう何も言えることはできなくて
隠れて授業に入ろうと部屋に入ろうと思ったんですけど
バレちゃったんです で
立ってるんですね 教授はまあ名前とか呼んでて
まあそこで授業始めるんですね
授業始めても本人が立ってるんですね
それはまあ ある時間経ったら
うん 座れ 顔を皆座れと言って
まあバカと言うんですね
まあ壁の方を見て あのバカと言ったところで微妙に微笑みがあるんですよ
それ 誰にも見つからない
もう鋭く私は見ていたんだからね
これ一ミリの 10 分の1ぐらいですよ
微妙に微笑み ああ なるほどと
その瞬間で私は分かったんですね
バカと結構聞こえるように言うんですよ
でも顔を見てなくて だからどうかね
やっぱりまあ子供やと
という気分があるんですよ
だからもう教授たちから学生からもうみんな悪口先生なんですけど
もうアホなことは結構やってましたし
もう座禅会とかやっていてえらい厳しいんだけど
本人が座禅中寝込んじゃって倒れちゃって
怪我までしてるんですね
もうもう情けないというと
もう面子がないというと切りがないんですけど
やっぱりそれでも私はこの人にはすごい人格があると
あれほど大勢の人々はとにかくもう文句言わないで抑えておくというね
だからそれはこの心の中に誰にもバレない状態で
だから表面的に見せるところではなくて
裏の状態というのがあるんですね
時々同じ正直で場合もあるし
その場合はすごい楽ですよ
育てるのは 例えば内面的にもすごく怒っていて
表面的にも怒っている場合は解決しやすいんです
内面はもう怒り一色なのに
もう慈悲ばっかしもう表現しちゃうと
親切で人を助けてあげる
あれやこれでもなかなか大変育ちにくいんですよ
誰でも誤解するんですね
だからお釈迦様が涅槃に入る前に
人間にはまあ一応正直になりなさいよと一言葉を残しちゃったんです
なぜかというと ブッダにその能力があるんだけど
弟子たちにはないんです
絶対表面に出てこない性格を読み取る能力はないんです
だってデータがないんだから
表面に出てこないということは
心の中を見ても深度がないんですよ
私でも心の深度でチェックするんですけど
この深度もないと もうどうしようもないんですよ
電波がないと で お釈迦様にはそれは何のことなくできましたけどね
だから あんた方のためになるんだからね
正直になりなさいと 正直になるということはすごい楽でしょうしね
だから自分がだらしないんだったら
だらしないことに正直になってほしい
自分がもう食べ物に目がない
えらいもう依存症だったら
もう私はそんなもんやということでね
正直になるというところが大事なんです
別に良い人間 完全な人間になれという話じゃないんです
裏と表は正反対にしないでくれと
そうするとお釈迦様の弟子たちは結構困りますよと
もう失敗するでしょうしね
瞑想指導したっても 失敗したっても
ボスは損しませんよ 瞑想する新しい方々が損するだけなんですね
自分が正直じゃないんだから
3番目は怒りか慈しみかということですね
4番目はティーヌミッダがあるか
ティーヌミッダーセ ティーヌミッダっていうのはこの渾身睡眠で
なんかね まあ眠り姫というか
まあ寝ることがすごい楽しくて
仕事をするだけでも早くこれ終わって寝たいとかね
そういう性格 時々いますよ
まあ私は寝たいんだからと早く行って寝るんだけど
心の内面はすごい活発的
活発的 だからこんな無駄なことをやるやるんじゃない
寝ると いう人もいるし
すごい元気で明るくて活発で行動はしてるんだけど
裏がね 暗い 機能しない
そういう性格の人々もいる
あるいは内面的には活発的で明るくて
表面的にも活発的に明るい人もいる
内面的にも暗くて眠気で
表面的には暗くて眠ている人もいる ４
種類ありますよ この４種類はこの４番目なんで
だから全部４種類 ４種類ですよ ４
つ書いてましたけど ４
掛ける４で１６種類なんです
人格分析するときは １６
種類の人格になるんです
意味は精神的に依存するか
明るさに活発になるかという 2つで
どちらが表面かっていうね
どちらが裏ですかと 隠しているのかと
もう大人 are と同じですよ
もう裏返しちゃうと白い
また裏返しちゃうと暗いと黒いとかね
この浅いの場合はもう正反対を見せるんです
それで大人の場合は表の方が機能しますけど
浅い場合は裏の方が本物なんです
表面的に明るく振りまい回っても
裏が暗いんだったら それが本物なんです
これ全部まとめてね この場合は心の裏を読む
裏が一番大事なんです
で 例えばまあ この人は怒っているが
性格的には優しい人なのだとかね
いうと読みが正しいんですよ
そうであるならば この人は怒っているし
性格も悪いんだと 言うとも
それも裏を読んで言わなくちゃいけないです
これが浅いの世界で で
また別な項目に入りますけど
さらに裏があるという
裏の裏もあるんです 簡単だと思ったでしょ
癖の話は ちょっと休憩いたします